but i think it's actually very
interesting to understand
the deal between apple and google and i
think that
david and i were pretty well prepped for
it because we did this um top 10
acquisitions of all time
episode and all nine of the ten
were revenue creative where uh you know
the companies combined and then made a
crap ton of money like facebook bought
instagram and then made a crap
hold on maybe i should guess these hold
on ooh what do you think
yeah you won't get two yeah what do you
mean hold on no
don't be don't be so sure okay uh well
microsoft bought
powerpoint back in the day um i believe
they bought excel
uh no no no just powerpoint so that was
an interesting one but i don't know if
that would be on your list
um clearly applied semantics that google
bought and youtube google bought
and answered on the list yeah android so
youtube
android i don't know if you put applied
semantics but that's what created ad
words which are the ads that are on
other sites but maybe you left that one
off
we did you so well uh overture that
yahoo bought which really inspired
everybody and then
yeah oh that was on your list uh it was
not on the list but um because it was
weird what all happened
and then you obviously have instagram
whatsapp so there's four right there
uh whatsapp was an honorable mention oh
an honorable mention okay
because it was speculative it was very
speculative that's true
now you wouldn't put oculus on that list
because nothing's happened there
there's is there anything that apple has
ever bought that's
been a revenue driver let's
think that through here well they made
one enormous acquisition that has to be
on there
it's you have to squint to call it a
revenue driver but
it's the most important thing they've
ever done
really what is it they bought next
oh well played gentlemen well played
they yeah that was an acquis that was an
aqua hire because they did buy siri
but siri is garbage i mean the fact that
syria is still so shitty is just
unbelievable oh wow that's a great pull
and then we had
um i think these were honorable mentions
but we had pa semi and authentic
uh which uh is apple silicon uh-huh
huh all right well done who else was on
the list anybody else
so the big one you missed um which is
the number two which
shook david and i both is uh double
click
oh yeah double click by google of course
yeah they brought that out for like
three or four
billion i think it was all displayed
three billion
three billion and it's gotta have made
it's kind of made over a hundred billion
we estimate 122 billion a value or 120
something
a couple of billion a year for a decade
yeah um
doubleclick was the original silicon
alley company that's right right
here i interviewed them for silicon
alley reporter in the first issue
when they were at a company called poppy
tyson poppy tyson was an ad agency and
kevin ryan and kevin o'connor
were building doubleclick inside of the
poppy tyson office
oh no because they wanted to be next to
an advertiser so they
poppy tyson gave them advertising space
and there were five of them and i went
to visit them
and they were like we're gonna build
this thing to serve the ads and i'm like
what do you mean ads and they're like
you know the banners that are on hot
wired
imagine if one company served them i'm
like but why would they need you to do
that this on their server it makes no
sense
i'm like oh well we can do average i was
like that's [ __ ] get the [ __ ] outta
here about that is nonsense
uh so this google one is not the one we
were expecting right
but david uh what do you expect real
quick the others you missed booking.com
uh yes yeah that's a good one oh yeah
there's two as you say so there's two
media companies
what do you think the other one is other
than oh it's gotta be marvel of course
yeah marvel yeah that's a no-brainer
marvel has
20 films that have done over a billion
dollars each and marvel franchise
that doesn't count merchandise it's got
to be 50 billion that's 5 billion to 50
right
i think we said espn's better but like
marvel's the second
longer that's for sure yeah right so
you're talking about that's a 30-year
story
yep we determined the absolute dollar
return
to disney on the marvel pickup uh was
16.3 billion
as evaluated by disney's market cap in
march we did the episode
and i think they spent 4 billion on it i
was just going by
20 movies times roughly a billion each
you know it's got to be and then i mean
we're not even looking forward like
those movies
just that one those three phases those
20 movies are going to generate
as much in the future as they've
generated already through disney plus
this episode though it highlighted so
much for us just the power of tech
business models because like take marvel
amazing incredible company it costs so
much to make those movies
instagram doesn't pay a dime for the
content on their network